si on décide c'est pas possible oui
merci qui vous demande pas des
changements
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui doivent
vous disent il faut changer dans votre
tête il faut tout changer parce que j'ai
trop de temps libre
parce que honnêtement là il ya beaucoup
de nouveautés et on sait qu'au bout de
15 jours il rembarre trois aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à ça c'est la
chaîne c'est si tous n'ont pas dit c'est
vous tous se soit fait je vous dire j'ai
deux mois de vacances
oui je pense que les prochaines faudra
réduire voilà je vous dis non et donc
voilà je cogite j'ai envie de faire des
trucs voilà mais j'aime bien et ça c'est
qu'il fait de tenter des choses voilà je
vous le dis et même si je vous dis je
pense que je fais de la télé moi pour
les téléspectateurs
vous le savez et à chaque fois j'ai
envie de dire j'ai envie de leur montrer
des nouveautés des nouvelles truc
dénouer je vous dis bien peut-être ils
vont kiffer tout ça et à chaque fois on
me fait plaisir en début d'année
croyant faire plaisir aux
téléspectateurs et en fait je me trompe
wichegrod vous êtes un anxieux joyeux
vous avez peur de mourir vous avez peur
17 mai résume à quoi en fait moi je sens
cette fébrilité chez vous et on vous
avez besoin
tu as vu ma photo tu l'as en affaiblit
d'annoncer un tass que ce soit mauvais
on changera après ouais c'est vrai que
moi je voulais savoir vous préféré
écouter vos fans zone où vous conseiller
en communication si vous en avez a
franchement mes fans 12 alors je les
écoute tout le temps sur twitter voilà
je suis tout le temps je regarde un peu
ce qu'il dit je leur réponds même très
souvent aux omp voilà tout voilà je suis
je suis avec téléspectateurs roche
consommer et donc là c'est vrai que
j'essaie voilà de faire une émission
comme il la rêverie
alors je sais que tout l'été vous
croisez beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
monde et que aurait général quand
quelqu'un vous dit pas moi j'aimerais
bien revenir autour de la table
vous dites basse vient de perdre dans le
pilat comme à la maison mais à un moment
vous vous dites pas mais ben y'en a trop
pourquoi tiendra pas ouais bah j'ai
essayé de faire une plus grosse table
voilà alors bébé moi une chine qui sont
intelligents bien sûr il faut dire aussi
un petit peu les coulisses de l'argent
c'est vrai que le reste de l'année on
communique beaucoup tous les deux et
l'allaiter ans par le moins donc tu
reviens avec terme j'aimerais questions
intelligentes franchement puisque
sélection je me pose est ce qu'à une
seule personne une seule parce qu'on
sait que nous non une seule personne que
tu écoutes quand il te dit tu devrais
faire ça ou tu raques donne un conseil
franchement tu rentres chez toi qui dis
là j'ai peut-être stéphane courbit le
patron de tout ça je sais pas ce qu'elle
fait non non c'est vraiment si les
téléspectateurs avant tout les fans nous
franchement avant toute chose sinon
j'écoute j'écoute bien sûr j'écoute tout
le monde voilà j'écoute aussi bien et je
peux écouter eric du public
mokhtar qui me donne un conseil mais
j'écoute surtout les téléspectateurs
parce que je pense qu'ils ont le
meilleur regard sur les missions et sur
la télé moi ce que j'aime bien c'est que
vous détestez l'immobilisme toujours en
mouvement en train de chercher des trucs
mais j'ai quand même une question qui me
taraude
il ya plein de nouveaux creux qui
chroniqueur chaque année est ce que
c'est parce que vous n'avez pas
confiance en nous non c'est pas ça c'est
pour aussi bois l'année de nouvelles et
merci voilà mais c'est vrai que à chaque
fois voilà gâteau il y aura des nouveaux
aussi qui rentre au moins forcément mais
en tout cas voilà je voulais vous le
dire
chaque année c'est vrai qu'on démarre
doucement des pmp ça fait six ans que ça
dure je me rappelle moi première année
j'avais vu un article qui disait hanouna
et ils finissent de riz de la deuxième
année et pmp voilà et tous les ans on
démarre doucement et ça monte de semaine
en semaine et c'est vrai qu'à les
derniers encore on a démarré je me
rappelle on a fini la semaine à 800
mille téléspectateurs hull combien la
première semaine
et voilà après à chaque fois ça ça ça
cartonne et vous êtes très nombreux à
nous suce de toutes les façons quoi
qu'il arrive et je vous le dis même si
les chiffres voilà été un petit peu dur
à semaine dernière comme les années
précédentes d'ailleurs c'est exactement
pareil je vous le dis les chiffres sont
quand même très très bon et on est tous
très contents et on sera là pour
longtemps merci en tout cas d'être
définition c'est tout le temps pareil
tous les ans on démarre doucement d'état
le diesel et c'est vrai que ça parte